the candidate does the presentation then
there's public questions so anyone in
the room we then excuse the public and
leaving the committee behind which is
Aaron Steve myself and Dina demen or
Cushman from Bethesda Maryland and and
then then the exam committee excuses the
candidate and we make a decision as to
whether thesis is successfully defended
so our candidate today who most people
in the room know is dr. Tracy edinger
who is also a postdoc fellow funded by
the National Library medicine and she's
been with us for a while and Tracy's
background is that she's a naturopathic
physician and she has been pursuing
informatics in her fellowship so I will
let her go from here thank you I let us
know Dean if you can't hear anything or
no I'm hearing you good fun okay good
you're very quiet around okay okay and
then I guess we're actually streaming
this so so people out there in
cyberspace want to ask a question tweet
at ohsu informatics all one word and and
also uh hashtag will see it anyways but
if you do hashtag hashtag d mice comp
dmic e conf will catch it as well and
I'll monitor the Twitter feed here so go
ahead great well thank you thank you all
for coming my topic is evaluation of
clinical text segmentation to facilitate
cohort retrieval so what I was trying to
do was find their way to
make it easier to find different groups
of patients in medical texts I started
the project last summer at the National
Library of Medicine and then continued
it when I got back here that ohsu so to
give a little bit of background we all
know that electronic health records ehrs
are increasingly being used by
independent practitioners and in
hospitals and other clinics a big
incentive to do this has been the
funding from the US government has put a
lot of money into helping people
implement EHRs in an effort to improve
health care EHRs can improve health care
by making data available to providers in
a direct patient contact but also by
having that data available later on four
different secondary uses we can use the
information for quality improvement
disease surveillance business
applications research for a number of
different topics for all of those
secondary uses of data it's important
that we be able to retrieve the specific
group or cohort of patients that we're
looking for
in order to talk about how we're going
to retrieve patient cohorts we need to
take into mind how the data is stored in
the EHR some of the data is stored in a
structured format where you have a fixed
finite list of codes or text elements
that you can use to enter into the data
a lot of it is stored as text free text
there's also images waveforms multitude
of different ways to store the data the
way that the data is stored is going to
determine how you can retrieve it a
number of studies have looked at
retrieval of patient cohorts using
structured data trying to retrieve
cohorts with structured data is going to
give you the most accurate results in
terms of retrieving exactly what you're
asking for and the full cohort of what
you're asking for but it might not
retrieve all of the patients that you're
really trying to capture one study
looked at this problem looking at
electronic health records over a
ten-year period at one institution they
looked at retrieving patients who have
had colonoscopies using the procedure
codes and looking at the text and found
that using the procedure clothes hugs
only let them retrieve a percent of
development patients so it's important
that we able to be able to use the text
to help retrieve the full cohort that
we're looking for and there have been a
few large-scale studies that have tried
to improve the ability to do this one
group that's working on this is
informatics for integrating biology and
the bedside or I to bj and they've
looked at retrieving cohorts of obese
patients for looking at retrieving
smoking status of patients the
electronic medical records and genomics
network or emerge has also looked at
retrieving patient cohorts over
different from different
sets of electronic medical records
focusing on similar cohorts and also
diabetic patients and patients with
histories of cardiac cardiac disease the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology text retrieval conference
medical records track or truck med is
another large-scale work that tried to
foster improvements in retrieving
patient cohorts a lot of the work that
was done at ohsu for track men has
formed the basis of this project so I'm
going to talk a little bit about Trek
med and how information retrieval worked
for that project for Trek men every
there were eighty eight participants
across the United States they were each
given a set of different clinical topics
and a set of de-identified medical
records and the goal was to retrieve all
of the patients relevant to each topic
from that set of records they develop
search systems and algorithms to try to
retrieve those documents for patients
and then when a search system runs as
search it'll return a ranked list of
documents that might be relevant to the
topic with the highest rank one being
most likely to be relevant and then on
down to the least likely to be relevant
for Trek med all of those results were
pooled from all of the participants and
all of the runs that they did and then a
subset of the documents was judged for
relevance and then performance of
individual participants and runs who was
judged against those judge documents
so back to retrieving cohorts from
clinical texts there are a number of
features of medical texts that make it
difficult to search there are a lot of
differences in terminology and spelling
or you might have multiple terms that
refer to the same condition or different
ways to spell things multiple meanings
four terms that might be context
dependent there are a number of acronyms
used in medicine that are have different
meanings depending on the context as an
example es can stand progress sounds in
a respiratory exam or bowel sounds in an
abdominal exam medical text often refers
to things that happen at different
points in time so you might have a
documentation of past medical illness
turi of a patient the current history
and possibly references to potential
future illnesses medical text also has a
lot of negation it's really important to
document findings or the absence of
findings and it's as important to
document the presence of them so you'll
find a lot of negation there are also
references to illnesses and other people
particularly in the family history
clinical text is structured in a way
that helps provide clues for somebody
reading it to resolve some of those
ambiguities a typical structure of a
medical note is using the soap format
where the subjective section documents
making that the patient reports to the
clinician the objective section
documents things that can be measured or
observed the assessment documents the
clinicians thinking about what's going
on with the patient and the plan
indicates what will be done and within
the subjective and objective section are
further subsections in a history this
objective section will be broken down to
distinguish the chief complaint history
of the present illness where the
clinician will document everything
leading up to or around that illness
past medical history social history and
family history and in the objective
section on a physical exam typically
find different sections for different
body systems so if we look a little bit
closer at a chart note this one
documents that the patient had an ulcer
at age 10 so if we're searching in this
set of documents for patients with
ulcers we're going to retrieve this
document even though it's not one that
we're looking for it also documents
family history of strokes and similarly
if you look for stroke you're going to
retrieve this even though it might not
be the one you want a number of
algorithms have been published by
different researchers that break the
text down into these different segments
in all of the papers the researchers
documented how well their algorithm
worked at breaking segments apart but I
couldn't find any published studies that
evaluate whether segmenting actually so
the hypothesis of this project was
that's searching the segmented clinical
text could improve the accuracy of
retrieving patient cohorts so for my
project I obtained a set of clinical
documents segment of them I developed a
set of topics for different patient
cohorts I developed a set of queries for
each cohort with and without sections
and then I judged a subset of the
documents for relevance to see how the
segment of queries performed and then
analyzed the results the data that I
used was the mimic to database this is a
research database developed by MIT
philips medical systems and beth israel
deaconess medical center it contains
de-identified data for ICU patients
neonatal and adult patients it's a
relational database that contains
structured and unstructured text there
are about 25 25 thousand patients in
there and four types of clinic notes
there are discharge summaries m denotes
radiology reports and their sing ducts
this is what the documents looked like
before they were segmented all the text
in the document was embedded in opening
and closing XML tags labeled texts so if
you search you're searching the whole
note and then after I segmented they
look like this where each section was
broken apart and again indicated by
opening and closing xml
tags the the tags were inserted
automatically using a program that
looked for indicator text there was a
long list of indicator texts that i
developed and every time the program
found that in the clinical document that
would insert the XML tags so to come up
with the indicator text I started with a
list that had been developed at the NLM
for track med and then I examined the
mimic documents to see what needed to be
added to it so I looked at a subset of
each of the four types of documents
listed all the possible ways that the
vindicator text would be identified and
those were put into the list that the
tool used so for example here the
allergen section is indicated by
allergies colon allergies dash allergy
to allergic to so when the automated
tool looked they wouldn't find any one
of those variations and tagged Eva's
allergy section each time it found any
of that indicator text that would pin in
the opening time for that section and
then just before the opening tag would
put in the closed time for the previous
section so it didn't actually look for
the end of a section was implied by the
presence of the beginning of a new one
the search engine that I used was a
search engine developed by the National
Library of Medicine the SE search engine
it was developed to help non clinicians
search medical literature and it does
that by mapping terms through the
unified medical language system so that
a non clinician can put in a term and it
will be mapped to a clinical term that
might not have the same words but simply
the umls does that turn mapping by
concept so each different term is mapped
to a specific concept and that lets it
relate the terms that are equivalent the
SE search engine maps the text that's
entered into it two concepts in the umls
so in the mimic data it would search
every word there and every time found
something it would tag it to 1v1 mls
concepts and it does the same thing when
you put in a search query it'll look for
your terms and match them to you MLS
concepts so that they can be equated
when you run a search in SE you receive
a list of documents that it has flagged
as possibly relevant to the topic
they're ranked from possibly most
relevant to least relevant and then se
also assigns a score between zero and
one indicating the likelihood that it's
relevant to the topic for the term
matching that se uses
with the umls there are five different
levels of mapping that you can select
and for this project I use three of
those no expansion tells se to look
learn exact little match so if you know
you want to look for Hashimoto's
thyroiditis and not anything else you
can indicate that you want to do that
concept expansion will branch out to
include sentiments of search terms so
here it'll match cashing motifs android
itís to autoimmune thyroiditis and
relaxation expansion breaks up the
sections of the search tech and we'll
look for sentence fragment so in this
case people in all forms of thyroiditis
not just bottle youth for my clinical
topics I again began with topics that
were developed for track men because the
datasets used for the two projects were
different i had to modify them for the
mimic data the trek data set included
emergency department reports and reports
from all patients who have been admitted
to the hospital whereas the mimic data
only included ICU patients so there were
some tweaks that had to be made to the
topics to make them relevant to the
current data set the final set included
22 different clinical topics
and my queries from the queries in SE
are boolean expressions that are
composed of terms and operators the
terms are the concepts that you want to
find in the documents and the operators
determine how the searches are performed
the primary operators are and or not so
for example diabetes and thrombocytosis
that query will specify that both of
those topics have to be in the document
in order to retrieve it celiac disease
and not celiac artery specifies that the
the document has to contain celiac
disease and not contain celiac artery
bed sore and pressure ulcer is going to
look her one or the other or both the
queries were developed initially without
sections very development was an
iterative process I developed the query
ran it against the data looked at the
data that I retrieved and then refine
queries as needed to either avoid
retrieving non relevant documents or to
try to pick up more of the relevant
documents I didn't use any site specific
details because I wanted the results to
be as generalizable to other datasets as
possible once I had the baseline query
written changed it to use the sections I
tried to use the same terms and boolean
operators as much affected but in some
cases it wasn't possible because of how
the sections changed the query and then
I again ran the queries against the data
and revised almost necessary and then
once they were both complete around them
and recorded all the documents that were
returned
so here's an example of a query with and
without the sections the topic is
patients with diabetes who also have
thrombocytosis and the baseline query
looks for both of these terms in the
document the section query looks for
from bo psychosis anywhere in the
document but then is very specific about
where in the document it looks for
diabetes in order to avoid thinking
about people with the family history of
diabetes or maybe a mention of it in the
social history for sampling the
documents I my queries returned over
12,000 documents so I could not read
them all and judge them for relevance so
I had to sample a subset of them so I
focused on the difference in scores for
the documents retrieved by the baseline
and segmented queries to determine which
documents I'll example when both queries
return the same document i looked at up
to 10 with the highest difference in
score in either direction where the
segmented score was higher than the base
score or the segment that's where i was
lower than the base score and then i
also sampled documents that have been
returned by one query but not the other
because of the way that the queries
return documents and a lot of the stamp
are a lot of the documents have the same
score I didn't always have my ideals
full of 40 documents per topic so my
total sample size was 574 documents but
the sample sizes range from 10 to afford
for each of the topics and the average
was 26 documents per topic to evaluate
whether the top documents were relevant
to the topic and to evaluate performance
I looked through each document and then
coded several different things whether
it was relevant to the topic whether the
segmentation had been done correctly
whether segmentation help retrieval and
why and whether and why any non relevant
documents were retrieved so the
documents that I retrieved we're mostly
discharged summer is almost 400 on them
I got back 142 radiology reports sorry
that I judged and 37 nursing notes there
weren't any md notes in the set that I
judged but the m denotes pertained only
to neonatal of patients and none of the
topics for and say we're all for adults
so that's what we expected I looked at
relevance of the documents to the topics
and the top row shows all relevant
documents there were 343 that were
relevant 246 of those were retrieved by
both queries 20 of those were retrieved
by the segment inquiries only 77 by the
base only the next row shows the non
relevant documents there were two
hundred thirty one of those eighty two
were treated by both queries segmented
queries retrieved only six non relevant
documents that weren't retrieved by the
base queries and the base clear is
retrieved 143 documents that weren't
retrieved by the segmented queries and
then the bottom line shows all of them
together I split it out into how many
relevant documents the segmented queries
retrieved out of all documents retrieved
by the segmented queries and about 75%
of the documents retrieved by the
segmented queries were relevant compared
to fifty-eight percent for these queries
I looked at reasons that non relevant
documents were retrieved and this is a
summary of them and I'm not going to go
into a lot of detail on this right now
because it was not the main focus of
this project but they followed similar
research that we've done in the past
where there were a lot of irrelevant
references to conditions like in family
members or other people past or future
conditions that weren't current
conditions that were mentioned but not
actually diagnosed conditions that were
denied or ruled out I did have a couple
of reasons for retrieving non relevant
documents that were unique to this
project one was an issue with mapping of
terms that came up with the topic
patients with HIV aids there aids in SE
map to a prior to mutant deficiency
syndrome aids assist help
other things totally unrelated and then
there were several cases where the query
just looking at performance of the
segmented queries there were a hundred
thirty-two documents that were not
retrieved by the segmented query because
it was able to avoid looking in certain
sections of the document and similarly
there were 20 documents where the
segmented query was able to focus on
specific sections and retrieve relevant
documents one of those topics was
patience with both taking atypical
antipsychotics without a diagnosis of
bipolar disease or schizophrenia where
the base query was excluding those
diseases from the document but the
segmented period was able to avoid
looking in the family history where a
lot of those fair relevant references
were found in most of the cases the
performance of the theory was not
related to segmenting at all in 80 cases
the query just didn't look in the right
sections and so the segmented queries
didn't retrieve relevant documents there
were 18 documents that weren't segmented
correctly where that had an impact on
retrieval and one document where the
condition was noted in a section of
notes that it's not normally it was a
patient with delirium and it was
mentioned only the social
mr. so a little more detail on some of
these where the segmented documents were
able to avoid retrieval for segment of
queries sorry we're able to avoid
retrieval of non relevant documents here
two of the topics where that helped
patients who developed on both side of
peenya and pregnancy the neonatal notes
will often document the mother's
pregnancy history so when I was
searching for these conditions it was
pulling onto the base query was pulling
a lot of neonatal notes but the
segmented period was able to focus on
sections where the where the condition
of the actual patient was documented
like the chief complaint or a discharge
diagnosis or admission diagnosis
patients who have gluten intolerance or
celiac disease the celiac disease was
being confused with the celiac artery so
the queries specified the celiac artery
not present in the document but that was
causing confusion in the segmented query
was able to avoid those by focusing on
specific sections there were 20
documents that were retrieved by the
segmented query because it was able to
focus on specific sections I think I
mentioned earlier patients taking
atypical antipsychotics without a
diagnosis of schizophrenia or bipolar
the segment of query was able to avoid
looking in the family history section
and someone's
to retrieve relevant documents and
patients with low back pain who had
imaging studies lumbar was used in that
query as a synonym for low back and that
was picking up patients who had had
lumbar punctures so both queries
excluded lumbar puncture but the
segmented queries were able to focus
that on procedure notes and so it was
picking up patients who had low back
pain and had happened to have lumbar
punctures in several cases the query
just didn't look in the right section
patients with thyrotoxicosis treated
with beta blockers and some of the
thyroid toxicosis was noted in the
preamble and the history of the present
illness and my segment aquarist didn't
look there and patients with colon
cancer who had chemotherapy in most of
the cases there the patients were
admitted for different conditions so the
colon cancer was noted in past medical
history even though it was a current
condition there were a few cases where
the document wasn't segmented correctly
not had an impact on retrieval in all of
these cases there wasn't an explicit
section heading so the section that I
was looking for had actually been put
into the previous section for example in
one topic delirium was mentioned in the
physical exam but that didn't have an
explicit heading so
incorrectly included in the social
history where I was not looking and the
other one was looking for patients with
depression which was noted in the
problem list but not split from the
allergy section that was not looking
allergies for depression and again i
found one case where a condition was
noted in the section of the notes you
didn't expect it so to analyze my
results I looked at a couple of
different things I looked at a
correlation to indicate whether the
segmented query had an impact on
performance and I also calculated
precision recall and fallout I used
Matthews correlation coefficient this is
a measure that's used in machine
learning to evaluate the performance of
a binary system and it is stable and
valid with small sample sizes which was
good because the sample sizes i use for
small to calculate this i looked at the
difference in score between the
segmented and these queries if one of
the queries didn't return a document i
used a score of zero for that if the
segmented score was higher than the base
then it was considered a positive
finding if it was lower than the base it
was negative finding and then I split
those into whether the document was
wrong
Matthews correlation coefficient ranges
from minus 1 to 1 if you have only true
positives and true negatives you know
you're the MCC is one indicating that
there's perfect correlation between the
performance of your system and the
results if it's negative one you'll get
that if you only have false positives
and false negatives indicating that the
system did exactly the opposite of what
you wanted and if they're mixed equally
it'll be zero indicating that the system
didn't have any impact on performance
the calculation for MCC is shown at the
bottom and here are the results across
the different queries there were six
squared are six topics where I couldn't
calculate it because of a zero in the
denominator and the scores here range
from minus 22.9 i've calculated
significance for all of them and think
eight of them were significant to at the
point 05 level and six at point o 1
overall the average was a little bit
over point for and that was also
significant and that indicates that
sectioning or using the section
communities have moderate improvement on
me Paul this is one of the topics where
I couldn't calculate
correlation coefficient both queries
returned almost the same set of 4,500
documents with identical scores I was
only looking at documents with different
scores so my sample for this topic was
only 10 documents that were retrieved
only by the base query patients with
diabetes who also have rhombus I ptosis
had the highest MCC appoint 91 in this
case the base query retrieves 10
documents that were not retrieved by the
segmented query those were the true
negatives and this was the lowest one
patients with esophageal cancer for
develop pericardial effusion the MCC
here was minus point to and there were
seven documents that were relevant but
retreat formed by the base query causing
the school to be lower I also calculated
precision recall and follow precision
well and these are a little bit
different from how they're normally
calculated because I was only looking at
the documents that I judged not the
entire sample so for this case precision
was the number of relevant documents
retrieved divided by the number of
documents judged recall was the number
of relevant documents retrieve / all
relevant documents judged and fallout is
the number of non relevant documents
retrieved / all non
documents judged this is precision for
the segmented and base query segmented
results are red and the base ones are
blue and in most cases the base query
outperformed the segmental queries and
speakers nuts that I couldn't get to I
don't remember which one that is I think
that was the patients taking atypical
antipsychotics where the segmented query
had perfect precision at the base query
10 this is recall and again the base
queries almost across the board
outperform the segmented queries except
for that atypical antipsychotic topic
and this is fall out we're in this case
the lower the number the better the
performance because you don't want to
retrieve non relevant documents and here
the segmented queries outperform the
base queries in all cases about one
so overall segmented fairies return
fewer documents but the ones that they
returned were more likely to be relevant
to the topic it would possibly help to
combine the queries and maybe use the
base queries to retrieve your first set
of documents and then run the segment of
queries against them to get an idea of
which ones are more likely to be
relevant or not in this project a lot of
the queries perform better than others
and then some document types were
segmented better than others there were
also differences in what was documented
in the different document types I think
get into here there were a lot of
limitations so this work it was a really
small sample size in information
retrieval it's difficult to judge
hundreds of documents per topic instead
of less than 40 there was only one
person doing the relevance judgments and
it would have been better to have
somebody else doing the relevance
judgments and not the same person who
had written queries in the topics and
done all the searches there were a lot
of inaccuracies in identifying the note
segments especially when they were not
explicitly headed and the queries
themselves needed a lot of improvement I
tried as I went along to improve them
but when i restarted by the sample by
comparing scores a lot more room for
improvement emerged so future work in
this direction I think would include
using one of the validated algorithms to
segmental text definitely using a larger
samples
and then independent relevance judges so
that it's not the same person doing all
pieces of the work and then again
different clinical notes document
different types of things or document in
different ways the nursing notes don't
tend to document the diagnosis as much
whereas the discharge summaries document
diagnosis assessment work up and the
radiology reports don't tend to document
or diagnose things as definitively where
they're often saying this finding is
consistent with this so developing the
queries to take into account those no
differences would be very helpful I also
think it would be a good idea to include
structured data and unstructured data
together because that would more
accurately reflect what happens in the
real world so think I would like to
thank all of you for being here I'd like
to thank my advisor and committee bill
Hirsch Dina dem nourishment Aaron Cohen
and Steve Bedrich the demise faculty
staff and students like to thank the NLM
for my funding and for providing
resources for this project and Swapna
abhyankar Russell loan and Francois
slain for their clinical and technical
expertise
any questions for Tracy I don't see any
tweaks question so some of the retrieval
errors you found had to do with the
queries you think now that you've
promised you could improve both the
segmented into non segmented queries and
stenton do you think that there is more
last opportunity to improve one of the
kinds of queries versus the other now
that you have a lot more experience with
this I think they could both be improved
I think the segmented queries can be
improved for them and not simply once I
thought about showing an example of one
of them but some of them got to be
really long when I split the documents i
ended up with 36 different sections and
so to be really complete there were
cases where I ended up with a lot of
phrases or whenever in the query and
there were places where i didn't had to
develop the query quite a success
so to help me understand what queries so
did you kind of develop them south where
did you go off of previous research to
kind of get it started and then it
evolved I started with queries that were
developed per track bed by ohsu and by
the NLM and kind of combined pieces of
those because they were the same topics
and then altered them to fit the mimic
data and kind of changes in the topics
and those queries came from just cuz she
might not be familiar with Trek
Manhattan not everyone in the room knows
what Trek methods but I mean just so
where'd the queries come from did
somebody write those queries in the
first place with an automatic processor
I wrote some of them just by looking at
the topic and the different
incorporating as many terms that would
refer to that as possible so would you
you would look at the data and and then
say okay maybe I need to add this in
because I'm seeing a pattern that's
helpful just as an FYI the topics in
trek med were designed to represent
patients who might be candidates for
clinical studies and we got those from a
variety of sources which but but the
idea was to in Trek med which we played
a significant role in was to identify
like Tracy's done cohorts of patients
who might be candidates for clinical
studies sort of medical records the
topic might be patients who had x y&z
but not why and were overage blah kind
of things so they weren't all that
detail
more fairly detailed somewhere a little
bit vague or like in patients with
cancer and and and the idea was that you
would we were trying to simulate the
task of a researcher tronco identified
cohort for a study sitting in front of a
search box in front of epic and
financial records that makes perfect
sense kind of it puts a little context
behind why you might be venturing down
that path and you brought up a good
point Steve with the age that was one of
the places where I had to adapt the
queries for mimic because there are no
ages in but there were age ranges in
track
the process of making these test
collections is very legally complicated
so often middle they'll sometimes have
kind of weird properties like for
example NICU and it don't but no pic you
in it it could be because there is some
legal reason why getting thick you did
it was harder or coordinate with in beth
israel deaconess where the people that
were in charge of the pic you weren't
interested in participating or it could
be any number of different things and it
leads to kind of strange uneven test
collections at least that's my
understanding of it is that i think so i
don't know if Dina has any the question
Dina was why there's no pedes ICU but
there was neonatal and adult do you know
about the mimic data Wyatt would omit
that yeah because they send pediatric
pieces to a different hospital oh there
we go okay perfect if they don't have
this real Deaconess interesting our
children snakes go children yeah yeah
once you segmented the text those little
fragments of texts that are labeled
those are not allowed to over abstract
do you think would that help at all if
they were
sorry it's it it's a total like goofball
I don't know if my hunt for the physical
exam I did not break out from different
sections of the PE because I didn't want
to end up with too many sections would
have been too much information and a
little findings but it might help in the
PE to have like subsections of that I
just wonder if there's pieces of text
that almost be labeled two directions
depending on which part you're looking
at so having overlapping they would not
try anything so you're saying like you
could if you want to know if there's
ever been so like colon cancer being in
past medical history and you want to get
part because sometimes its current but
you could include like chief complaint
history of present illness and past
medical all in one block oh I'm thinking
even finer grain like if you have a
piece of text 10 words and the first
eight words could be labeled one way and
the last eight words can be labeled a
different way but when the labeling
algorithm that first eight words gets
captured and labeled and then it leaves
out so you lose that second people I'm
just like oh those the only labeling
correct me if I'm wrong the only
labeling done here is really the
breaking them into sections so this
really isn't this more information
retrieval than NLP we're basically we're
just dirt races just segmenting the text
into the section so there's not any
further processing but but then actually
is honking or something okay because I
was mad I thought you were breaking
things like allergy and we're labeling a
piece of text I was like here this
indicates an allergy I could want
anymore but these were all sections that
are typically used when you're
documenting patient's history okay
the sick part of is that in most THR's
these things are actually stored
internally as structure in with this at
least this level of structure where you
know allergies are in one field and you
know maybe family you know past stuff
within one field and sign you know
credit observe science or another
building when he gets dumped to a
repository for something like this kind
of analysis usually that structure gets
thrown away sort of so so this is sort
of broke a very implicitly recovering
scriber rather than recovering special i
was there implicitly night see which is
one of the heightening things at work
animus kind of did if you ask me but
question about standards so you had a
lot of distress over some of the other
new targeted types might be more or less
able to pick in this segment estándar
segment did you look at the differences
by type and then did you try an appt
your segmentation approach to larger
standards like CDA a CCDA i did not do
that and what do you mean by looking at
them my type so you know there's a
prevalence of the area or the segments
and areas no types you sort of look at
that how it was across the different
types um a well-defined me where i guess
i observed differences i didn't analyze
them but there definitely were
differences and that's why i think if
something like this were to happen again
the query should focus on particular
note types because the discharge
summaries all had pretty consistent
section headings and
sections and the type of information
documented in each section the nursing
notes weren't as consistent and so there
were things that were documented in the
section that you wouldn't necessarily
expect it to be we're talking about bro
adding a table of that kind of thing
these many notes have these dis sections
you know breaking out at first cars your
write-up goes so it's easy enough to do
on this data set yeah the other thing
that sort of highlights for next step is
you know if you could automatically sort
of write a script that would create
these queries to actually add new type
is another layer to do that mean that's
looking for like ever goal but you can
sort of see you know if i look at your
title and center does that help me query
test a bunch of different things do i
find approaches that are more likely to
meet better I mean you saved your review
or a lot of work but you just missed
them on jury proceeding to recall
weren't as good with the segmented what
the fallout was really good that's good
trying to hear a big court for a try
although if you know you're looking for
100 patients you could use a segment of
query and probably come up with that
many and have you know it would be much
more likely that they'd be relevant yeah
and have less work to review that which
is why you presented the correlation
first the most positive representation
that concept essential agree mr. news
are some kind of fire some might be
reduced by these abuses how's your
patient cohort using her patients
retreat second person that's one issue
if you were to just is there some
difference like with the colon cancer
patients then actually that's that's an
interesting thought that we don't think
about much you know you know because we
have this hope that we're going to be
able to use narrative patient records to
extract all kinds of data and send
people for studies but of course there's
differences in how physicians document
and that can actually introduce bias and
that's a good point probably not
addressable in this study but I think
the other part of that that's crucial is
you know these are always like a first
touching a like if you're actually if
you think about the next step for a
cohort you actually do or formal
the living assessment for instance on a
set of patients and if the data is junky
you're going to be asking a lot of
patience a lot of information probably
your yield on those basically really low
and so for documentation probably needs
this patients less likely to be eligible
to study here wasting your time a lot
more and we never go double trailers
there's probably some fatigue that
creeps in people go in if you get too
many of them so I think that's really
very relevant and it's a sort of a very
different way it's the purpose to which
you put a tool like this as the primer
you know thinking about it differently
so that there's really good uses for
that idea
okay well if there's no other questions
from the public we can excuse the public
thank you for my [ __ ] thought Thomas
for my shorts off my foot